You'll recall that where we got to
last time is that there are lots of hot
Jupiters,
there are lots of hot Jupiters and uh,
the alternative theories that were
presented to explain the evidence for hot
Jupiters,
the evidence for hot Jupiters comes in
this form of these velocity curves where
you plot the radial velocity versus time
of the star and the star goes back and
forth and you infer from that that
there must be a planet going around it,
which is pulling the star back and forth.
Uh,
and uh,
some alternative explanations were
proposed to explain these kinds of data.
Those alternative explanations
didn't seem to work very well.
And so you have to kind of take
the hot Jupiters seriously.
Uh,
before I go on,
let me mention that by now,
hot Jupiters are not the only kind of
planets that have been seen this way.
There are also a planet in a now
known to have much longer orbits,
orbits up to a few years.
These are harder to see for two reasons.
First of all,
it takes you a few years to see him.
Uh,
and second of all,
because when the orbits get longer,
the velocities that they
induce go down because,
uh,
things in long orbit to go slowly.
Uh,
but nevertheless,
now we've been able to
see a bunch of things.
Oddly,
in many cases,
uh,
they turn out to have
highly elliptical orbits,
orbits in some cases,
uh,
not the hot Jupiters,
not the ones that are close in.
Those all are more or less circular.
Uh,
but some of these longer ones
have highly elliptical orbit.
That's also very weird in
terms of [inaudible] theories
of planetary formation,
uh,
because,
one of the things that,
uh,
are theories were designed to explain
was the fact that all the major planet in
our own solar system have orbits
that are close to circular.
It does a very good
job of explaining that.
And then,
uh,
naturally enough has trouble explaining
the ones we see that are in highly
elliptical orbits.
Oh,
uh,
highly elliptical.
Yes.
I didn't highly elliptical
orbits in some cases and adjust.
Uh,
so,
you know,
the way you recognize a highly elliptical
orbit is it's not your soil anymore.
It's got some other shape.
Uh,
so these come in periodic
but non sinusoidal,
uh,
velocity curves.
So all this is very amusing.
Uh,
and you pile up all these very strange,
uh,
kinds of planet or what
you think our planet,
uh,
but there's still sort of the nagging
question of whether these a radio velocity
curves might be explainable
in some other way.
And it would be awfully nice to have,
uh,
evidence,
of some other kind for the
existence of these planets.
This is,
this is,
you know,
what happens in science.
You find some kind of fairly
strong evidence for something,
uh,
but it would be way stronger if you
found two different kinds of evidence,
different collected in different ways
or reflecting different aspect of what
you're observing,
uh,
that both point in the same direction.
And,
uh,
at a certain point along the way about,
six years ago or so,
uh,
a new kind of evidence for the existence
of these planets was discovered.
And the first such case,
uh,
which is now a very famous
star for this reason,
uh,
was something called a HD.
Uh,
two oh nine,
four 58.
That's the name of the star.
And this was a hot Jupiter system.
Uh,
so this is the name of the star,
a hot Jupiter.
Okay.
Was discovered,
okay.
In the usual way by a
doppler measurements,
by radial velocity measurement.
Uh,
and then something else was discovered.
Okay.
So all,
let me show you what they
found in this system.
All right,
so,
uh,
let me explain what's plotted here.
Is the brightness of this system,
not the radio velocity.
This time,
the brightness against time.
Uh,
and so here it is on the 9th of September,
1999 and somebody is measuring
the brightness of the star,
this thing,
and it's set up in units so that
the average brightness is one.
And you can see these measurements
have a little bit of error in the,
they scatter around and then at a certain
point there's a dip and the brightness
of the star for a few hours.
Notice this is in days,
this is a 10th of a day.
So 2.4 hours,
something like that.
So for a few hours,
the brightness of this thing
dips down to about 98% of it,
of the brightness it has sowed.
So to loses 2% of its
brightness for a little while,
and then it comes back up.
Uh,
and then interestingly enough,
seven nights later on the
night of the 16th of September,
it did the same thing.
Now seven nights is an important number
for this particular system because it
turns out that the orbital
period of it's hot,
Jupiter,
which was already known at the time,
uh,
is three and a half days.
So this is exactly two orbits later,
the exact same dip occurred.
You couldn't see it one or a bit later
cause three and a half days later,
it's daytime.
Uh,
and uh,
one of the features of astronomy
is that you do it at night.
Uh,
and uh,
so you have to wait two days,
two orbits to see the same thing again.
So every,
uh,
every orbit,
there appears to be this little dip.
And what is happening is that this is
a system that's almost exactly edge on.
And what's happening is that the planet
is passing in front of the Star and at
once per orbit,
the planet gets in the way of the star,
the planets,
this little thing,
the stars,
a big thing.
And a small amount of the stars
light is obscured by the planet.
This is called a transit.
Uh,
so let me just write that down.
And then transit
are discovered.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
We'll come back to the,
to the overheads and amend it cause
I want to show you more plots.
Uh,
and it's the planet getting
in the way of the starlight.
And what this tells you also
is how big the planet is.
Because you've got a little disc in front
of a big disk and the amount of light
that's obscured,
this 2% tells you what the ratio of the
area projected by the planet compared to
the area projected by the entire start is.
So this gives you an additional piece
of information you already know the mass
of the thing for,
because you've measured
the radio velocity.
Now we also know its size.
Uh,
so this was very interesting and it is,
as I was saying just a second ago,
an entirely different kind of confirmation
of the existence of this planet.
So there's no pulsation going on here
because something that you not only are
getting the changes in velocity
of the planet you're seeing of,
of the star,
you're also seeing the light of the star
diminished when the planet passes in
front of him.
Uh,
and then so they decided this was
interesting and so they did the same
experiment except with the Hubble space
telescope instead of with some ground
based telescope.
This is what you see with Hubble.
Uh,
and you can see why humble
is a better telescope.
Uh,
then the grab based stuff,
this is exactly the same plot.
This is uh,
uh,
the average brightness of the
system outside of the transit.
Uh,
so this is 1.0.
This is 0.985.
So it's dropped down 1.5% in brightness.
This is in days in [inaudible].
Uh,
this is a 10th of a day here.
Each of these big ticks is a 0.05 of
the day and here's the star going along
perfectly normally.
And uh,
you get better measurements because
you're not distorted by the atmosphere.
And then all of a sudden the
thing drops and it gives,
has this very particular
shape to the light curve,
to the curve of brightness.
With time.
This shape is perfectly explained by
the hypothesis that you're passing and
opaque disc across the
surface of the star.
As the disc touches the star,
it starts to uh,
and gradually more and more
of the disc is over the star.
You get this steep drop here.
And then this rounded part down on the
bottom comes about because when you look
at a star,
uh,
the of the star,
the central portion of the star looks
a little bit brighter than the edges.
Because if you think
about looking at a sphere,
if you look at the center,
you're looking right at it.
If you're looking at the side,
you're sort of grazing the edge and it
turns out there's something called limb
darkening,
which comes about because of this.
So stars,
if you look at the sun,
for example,
the edges of the sun look a
little fainter than the middle.
And so what happens is as,
as this disc passes across
the face of the star,
it obscures successively brighter parts
of the star until you get down to here.
Then it obscures a gradually fainter
parts of the star until it gets to the
edge.
Now the disk is,
as it goes up here,
uh,
is passing beyond the edge of the star.
So this is exactly the
shape of a light curve.
You would predict if you passed
an opaque disc in front of a star.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it really works out remarkably well.
In fact,
uh,
there's a line underneath these points.
You can see it off here and off here,
uh,
which is a prediction and you can't see
the line because it's under the points
so nicely.
Uh,
so this works out incredibly well.
This is an old,
this is almost for sure.
Uh,
and opaque disk,
namely the planet passing
in front of the star.
So transits are discovered,
uh,
the dip in light,
due to a planet passing
across
the star.
No,
this does not happen in every hot
Jupiter because you have to be lined up
pretty,
uh,
pretty perfectly in order for the
planet to pass in front of the star.
That is to say,
uh,
if here,
here's you,
here's,
here's an observer,
uh,
here's the star.
Uh,
and,
uh,
if the planet,
if the orbital plane of
the planet looks like this,
uh,
then when the planet,
in front of the star,
it'll be below it.
So if you think about it,
imagine,
uh,
imagine a planet that's
orbiting like this.
Here's its star and it never passes in
front of the star because when it's,
when it's in front of the star,
it's below the star.
Whereas if it,
if it's exactly edge on,
then once per orbit,
it will pass in front of the star.
But you have to have a very precise
alignment for that to take place.
So,
uh,
requires,
a precisely,
okay,
uh,
edge on
alignment.
Okay?
But if you have such an alignment,
uh,
you know how these dips ought to line
up with the radio velocity curve.
So now what you see is your measure,
the brightness of the star versus time,
and you see these dips,
here's a dip,
then one orbit later you get
another dip and so forth.
Uh,
if you then at the same time
measure the radio velocity,
okay?
Uh,
and again,
this is the radio velocity of the star.
Then you know how this has to
take place because here you are,
you're looking at it and the
moment where the dip takes place,
the planet's got to be
exactly in front of the star.
That means the planet is at this
point in its orbit going that way,
for example.
And the star is in this part
of its orbit going that way,
which means this,
the radio velocity at the moment,
the dip occurs has to be zero because
for them to be lined up one in front of
the other,
they've both got to be going sideways.
And shortly before that,
the star was moving away from you
because they're moving into position like
this.
Shortly afterwards,
the star is coming towards you.
Uh,
and remember that positive
radial velocities are coming
towards going away from
you.
Negative velocities
are coming towards you.
So it used to be the star used
to be going away from you,
positive.
It's now at zero,
at the point of the dip,
and then it's going to
be coming towards you.
So it has to be that these
dips take place at that point
in,
uh,
in the,
curve.
And so here again,
it's got to be like this.
And so the way this has to work
out is something like this.
So you can predict what the radio velocity
has to be at the particular moment
where the transits occurred.
And this works.
This works for a HD.
Uh,
what is it?
Two Oh nine,
four 58.
So this works out.
Okay.
So now you've got a lot of evidence
that this really is a planet.
Not only is it moving the star back and
forth the way you expect the planet to
do,
it's also passing in front of that star
at exactly the moment you expect it to
pass in front of the star.
And the shape of the dip that it creates
is exactly what you would expect if you
pass an opaque disc in front of a star.
So now you've got a whole bunch
of different kinds of evidence,
uh,
you can ask,
does this prove it's a planet?
Uh,
and then you get into this
problem with scientific proof.
What does it mean to prove
something in science?
You could probably figure out some clever
way that it's actually a pulsating,
pulsating star,
uh,
which has a star spot on it that somehow
precisely mimics exactly the way a
planet would behave,
uh,
impossible that this would,
well now I should be careful with that
word in highly improbable that this,
uh,
would actually occur in real life.
So I think,
you know,
people have the feeling
that that science is,
is truth somehow.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
that you can prove things in science
kind of to a mathematical certainty that
actually isn't the case.
Uh,
the legal standard,
you know,
what you're familiar from cop
shows of beyond a reasonable doubt,
uh,
applies in science as well.
Uh,
and that's actually a more appropriate
standard to use for anything which,
Eh,
in,
in the law or,
or,
or in the natural world in which you,
uh,
try and reason by induction.
Uh,
and so I would say that this plus this
plus the shape of the mission of the
spectral lines,
which we talked about last time,
uh,
plus the shape of these depths,
that's proof way beyond a reasonable
doubt that there's a planet around,
uh,
around this particular star.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that really ended the conversation.
Yes.
Is it always directly,
and John is,
could there be a case in
which a little bit below.
So is it always edge on?
Uh,
well,
orbits don't change.
So for this object,
it's always add on.
For most objects,
it is not adjunct.
And so in fact,
what had happened was by the
time they discovered this one,
there were a couple of
dozen of hot Jupiters known.
None of the rest of them do this
because in all the rest of them,
the orbit isn't aligned properly.
And so the,
the planet never goes
in front of the star.
And so in the vast majority
of cases you don't get this.
And so they only,
they only discovered this after they'd
found so many of them that one of them
turned out to be aligned properly.
You know,
just by chance.
Is there a there,
is it possible for a core of it to knock,
never pass in front of the center?
No.
What,
what it does is it passes.
It's got to do this.
It's got to have some moment where the,
where the planet is as far
towards you as it can be,
and then it turns around and comes back.
But for most orbits,
at that point,
the planet will either be below or
above the star from your line of sight.
So imagine this orbit as the planet goes,
here's a star planets
going around the star.
It reaches its furthest forward point,
but it's well below the star
from your line of sight.
So it depends on,
on the angle of the orbital plane.
Does that make sense?
It doesn't happen.
You can pass,
you know.
Oh,
Oh yes.
Sorry.
A exactly right.
It doesn't have to pass
through the center of the star.
It can,
it can graze the tip at the
bottom of the star a little bit.
And in fact,
in this object,
uh,
you can tell how close to the center it
goes by the exact shape of the curvature
down at the bottom of that light curve.
Uh,
because you know what the
expected distribution of
brightness across the face of
the star is.
You also know something
about the radius of the star.
This is supposed to be a solar type star,
presumably has a radius of the sun.
If it passes a across,
uh,
sort
of grace is the bottom,
then the,
then the dip will be
shorter because it will,
it will pass through faster until you can
figure out exactly what the trajectory
across the thing is.
Most of the time it misses a,
and in this case you
can figure out that the,
uh,
that the angle of inclination,
so called,
which is 90 degrees,
if it's exactly edge on his 80,
I think 88 point something.
I don't remember the answer because it
doesn't go exactly across the center.
It goes sort of sort of halfway down.
Uh,
so yeah,
that actually gives you
additional information,
uh,
how long the dip is and what the exact
shape of the thing tells you which part
of the star it passes across.
Yes.
Good.
Thanks Bethany.
Other questions about this?
Yeah.
Discovered a planet through
transit without having to previous.
All right.
Have we discovered a planet through
transit without having discovered the
previous,
uh,
radio velocity curves?
Yes.
And we'll get to that.
Uh,
because,
uh,
let me just say this,
as soon as this was discovered,
people got way excited because it's
quite difficult to make these kinds of
precise radial velocity measurements.
You have to have very
specialized equipment.
Only a few people in the world can do it.
There's this bunch of people
in California who can do it.
in Switzerland who can do it.
US normal astronomers don't have
that kind of expertise and equipment,
but measuring a change in
brightness of a star by 2%,
that easy.
I can do it up on the up on Science
Hill in our little observatory up there.
In fact,
I have done it for this star.
Uh,
you can,
uh,
if the timing were better,
this star is up in the summertime,
unfortunately.
Uh,
and if it were up in the fall,
we would have this be an exercise in astro
one 55 because it's entirely straight
forward to go and measure a 2%
difference in brightness in a star.
Uh,
anybody,
you know,
with 2000 bucks worth of equipment,
you can go out into your
backyard and do this experiment.
This is a big deal.
So as soon as that was possible,
everybody got fired up.
You know,
I'm going to park,
I'm going to play this game myself.
Uh,
and we all laid very elaborate plans
for going out and finding zillions of
planets.
And the problem is that it has to be
exactly aligned edge on for this to even
occur.
And so most,
most stars with planets,
this doesn't happen.
And so,
uh,
you would have to observe many,
many,
many stars,
uh,
in order to see this one time.
So you have to,
yeah.
While it's easy to do for
any one particular object,
uh,
it's hard to discover them this way
because you have to do it in bulk.
A,
you have to look at many stars,
uh,
at once.
So then people thought,
well,
great,
we know how to do this.
We'll look at many stars at lunch.
We'll take pictures of star clusters of,
uh,
where there are lots,
lots of stars.
Uh,
and we'll just keep taking pictures of
these star clusters over and over again.
You'll look at 30,000 stars at a time,
uh,
and if one of them has a dip,
we'll find that dip.
And so the way we'll deal with the fact
that this doesn't always occur is by
looking at star clusters.
Uh,
and so they tried this again,
uh,
with the space telescope because it
works better at doing this kind of thing.
The problem with star clusters is the
stars are really close to each other.
So from the ground it
just looks like a mush.
Uh,
in this case you have to
see the stars separately.
So,
uh,
they took,
a particular star cluster also the
advantage of doing it from spaces,
no day time,
uh,
and so you can observe continuously.
So they took eight consecutive days
of Hubble Space Telescope time and did
nothing but look at a star cluster cluster
called fit famous cluster called 47
37.
Sergeant,
they took repeated images of this
star cluster and they figured,
uh,
we ought to see,
some number of a planet by the
transit method first in this cluster.
So just,
here's what the cluster it looks like.
Um,
so this on the left is a ground
based picture of this cluster.
And you can see what the problem with
observing this stuff from the ground is.
If you look down in the middle
and it's all mushed together,
you wouldn't be able to
pick out individual stars.
But then this box here,
uh,
blown up to the right
hand side of the picture.
This is what that little box looks
like from the Hubble Space Telescope.
And now you have the resolution
to observe each of these stars,
uh,
or many of them individually.
And so they took eight nights of
spa Hubble space telescope time.
That's a lot of time,
uh,
on the space telescope in space.
Telescope cost about a million
dollars a day to run a,
and so this is 8 million
bucks worth of observing time.
Um,
okay,
so what did they expect to see?
So
finding
yeah,
planets directly,
uh,
from transits
and so the observe
a cluster of stars.
Okay.
30,000 stars at a time.
So what do you expect?
Well,
it turns out from the
Reggio philosophy studies,
they'd gone and looked at a lot of,
uh,
sort of sunlight stars.
Uh,
so 30,000,
more or less sunlight stars,
I should specify,
uh,
from the radial velocity measurements.
From the doppler measurements,
they got answers like
approximately one out of 10 stars.
This is a rough estimate.
Have hot Jupiters and then how aligned
to do they have to be a approximately one
out of a hundred hot Jupiters.
Okay.
Is Aligned.
Yeah.
Properly,
uh,
to get a transit.
And so now you have a prediction.
You look at 30,000 stars,
a 10th of them have
planet that's 3000 planet,
uh,
one,
100th of those will be lined up in
such a way that you can see a transit.
Uh,
that's 30 transits predict.
Okay.
30 transits.
Yeah.
And it was that kind of calculation.
This is just a rough estimate,
but they had done this
much more precisely.
It was that kind of
estimate that persuaded,
uh,
the,
people at the Space Telescope
Institute to allocate all these,
uh,
all these many hours of space,
telescope time to,
to this project.
Uh,
the result,
yeah.
Was Zero transits,
none,
not seen.
And this was a little distressing except
it didn't take people very long to
figure out that they should
have known this in advance.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is,
you know,
you get a result and then of course
people and you get an unexpected result.
And then people start
writing papers which say,
well,
of course,
that's what you should have gotten.
Any fool could have predicted that you
would not see any transits in a cleaner
star cluster.
Uh,
except none of the fools did.
let's see.
Uh,
so,
uh,
but in retrospect it was clear that this,
that this wasn't going to,
uh,
give you the thing you thought
because of two factors.
First and Co why?
Uh,
so first factor in clusters,
the stars are really close together.
Stars,
uh,
they sometimes collide,
or more often have near collisions.
And when a star comes cruising
into your planetary system,
the star has a lot of gravity.
It's going to completely wreck the orbits
of the planet because you're going to
have the gravity of a second star.
And it turns out that what this
does is it liberates the planet.
And so yeah,
will,
uh,
disrupt
planetary orbits.
So you kind of don't expect
there to be any plant.
You expect it to be planets.
In the cluster,
but there'll be free floating planets
sort of wandering around the cluster
because they will have been detached from
their parents star by incoming stars,
uh,
by close encounters with
other stars in the cluster.
Uh,
uh,
put it this way,
the nearest star to
the sun beside the sun,
uh,
Alpha San is about a parsec away,
in a cubic parsec at the center
of one of these clusters,
there are a million stars.
Uh,
and so there are a million stars,
uh,
packed into the space where only one
star exist in our corner of the galaxy.
So they run around,
you know,
if you were in a cluster,
if you were in a planet on a cluster
and you're looking up at the sky,
the constellations would change from
year to year because the stars are so
nearby,
uh,
that their motions would
be readily apparent.
And once every few hundred million years,
a Star would come cruising into your
solar system and detached or all of the
planets from the style.
So you don't expect
there to be any planets.
Uh,
you also don't expect
there to be any planets.
For an entirely different reason,
which is one of the things
that had been discovered,
uh,
as they were piling up
all these hot Jupiters,
uh,
found by the doppler shift method is that
stars are more likely to have planets,
yeah.
Have Planet
if they have high amounts,
uh,
of heavy elements,
heavy elements.
Now,
let me explain that.
Uh,
most stars stars are
okay,
mostly.
Okay.
Hydrogen and helium.
Uh,
astronomers do chemistry
in a very peculiar way.
Uh,
we,
uh,
have we considered there three
kinds of things in the universe.
There's hydrogen,
there's helium,
and there's metal,
uh,
chemists.
Everything else is a metal.
I don't care if it's oxygen,
carbon,
whatever.
Uh,
the chemists get really
uncomfortable with this.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's like the,
the,
uh,
supposedly to primitive tribes.
I'm not sure if this actually exists,
but the linguists say there are,
there are tribes in the
world where they count one,
two,
and many.
Uh,
well,
this is how a straw,
I don't know if such tribes exist except
for the astronomers who really do,
uh,
and we count one,
one,
two,
and Manny and do we call a any
chemical elements heavier than helium?
A metal.
Uh,
so we have this concept
called medalists city,
which is defined to be
the fraction of something.
Of elements.
Yeah.
Heavier.
Then hydrogen and helium.
Okay.
Which are the first two
in the periodic table,
as you probably know.
So everything else is a metal.
The metal Felicity of the sun.
Uh,
sons,
medalists city.
Yeah.
It's about 2%.
Uh,
and the metal,
the city of the solar system
is therefore about 2%,
because the sons got all the mass,
uh,
and high medalists,
city stars,
by which I mean metal.
These greater than the sun,
greater than solar are more,
okay.
Likely.
Okay
to have planets.
This makes perfect sense.
This isn't the first thing in a
little while that's made any sense.
Uh,
because,
uh,
how do you make a planet what
planets aren't made out of?
Hydrogen and helium,
planets are made out of the other stuff.
Uh,
we're made out of silicon and iron,
uh,
and,
the Jupiter,
it's got a lot of ice.
And so all these kinds of
heavy elements you don't make,
you can't make a planet if all you've got
is hydrogen and helium because there's
nothing solid to,
to,
to have it for them.
And the only way you get to
keep your hydrogen and helium,
the 98% of the stuff that hydrogen and
helium is if you already have a big core
of heavier,
uh,
either rocks or ice or something else,
if you already have some metallic
in the astronomical sense,
uh,
core.
And so this makes perfect sense.
Uh,
if you don't have any metals,
you can't be forming planets.
And Star clusters of the,
of the kind that a humble observe,
uh,
are known.
And this particular one is,
uh,
to consist of low medalists
city plan a stars.
Uh,
in the case of a 47 talk,
the one we looked at,
uh,
it's the medalists city of the thing is,
I think about a fifth that,
of the Sun.
So it's got very substantially
fewer heavy elements.
So no planets.
So in two different ways,
this was a mistake,
right?
Uh,
but that was only realized afterwards.
And it's unfortunate that it was a mistake
in two different ways because if it
was a mistake in only one different way,
you would have learned something from
this because you would have confirmed the
idea that uh,
star close stellar encounters,
strip planets off of stars,
except maybe it's only because of the,
the low metal listening or you would have
confirmed the idea that low medalists,
the stars can't have
planets except in this case,
maybe it's just because of the,
the stars.
The planets had been stripped away.
So it's kind of unfortunate that there
were two excellent explanations different
from each other about why you should
have predicted this result before you
obtained it.
Uh,
however,
having done that,
uh,
it was clear what the
next experiment had to be,
that you want it to go out and try and
measure these transits in some region
that's a little less dense and
a whole lot more metal rich.
So next experiment,
which was done last summer,
uh,
didn't look at a star cluster.
It looked at the center,
a region close to the
center of the galaxy.
So this is lots of stars.
Okay.
But significantly less dance.
Then,
uh,
then what you would get in,
in the center of a cluster.
Okay.
Uh,
fortunately they'd put up a bigger camera
into the space telescope since then,
so you could cover more,
more of the sky,
which was useful.
Uh,
this is the camera,
by the way.
You may have read,
uh,
over the weekend,
Hubble's had a little bit of a problem.
Uh,
the electronics in this a wide
field camera have shorted,
have shorted out,
and so,
uh,
Hubble's kind of in
trouble until they get the,
uh,
the next visit because it's
major cameras now blind.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this happened,
I should say,
uh,
12 hours after the deadline
for submitting proposals.
Uh,
so there had been almost a
thousand proposals submitted
from around the world of
which may be only a fifth
would ever get done.
Uh,
people in our department and basically
every department in the whole,
uh,
astronomy department in the whole world.
We're going nuts trying to prepare their,
uh,
detailed proposals for using
the thing they submitted them.
And a few hours later it broke.
Uh,
and so then there was this nice little
email from the people at the Space
Telescope Institute saying,
uh,
you might want to reconsider and we've
created a new deadline three weeks from
now so that you can revise and extent
there are other instruments that still
work,
but not the camera's aren't as good.
Uh,
and so now everybody's scratching
their head and thinking,
can I actually do this?
And if I can,
what's the good strategy?
Do I want to try and do it now when the
competition is going to be much less
because the instruments are lousy or do
I want to wait until after September,
2008 when they're scheduled to go up and
replace the camera and repair the thing
and try and do it with
the good instruments?
Then when everybody else in the world,
there's going to want
to do their experiment.
Uh,
and so we're all grappling
with this at the moment.
However,
last summer this was working like crazy.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they did another one of these 10
consecutive days of observations,
but this time of the center of the galaxy,
which has lots of stars but less dense
than in the center of the cluster,
and also has the advantage
that many of these stars,
most of them are high
medalists city stars.
Okay.
Uh,
hopefully this'll work,
right?
Uh,
because you've eliminated both of the
excellent reasons why it didn't work the
last time.
Uh,
so here is the field of view that they
were looking at this as a tiny piece of
the center of the galaxy.
Lots and lots and lots of stars,
which is good because
you want to see them.
And these little circles here,
which are numbered from one to 16,
I believe,
uh,
our circles around little sunlight stars,
you can see the stars in
the middle of those circles.
You probably have a
hard time seeing what's,
let's turn the lights down.
This is kind of a nice picture.
Uh,
this is what the center of the galaxy
looks like to the Hubble Space Telescope
and,
and these bright things,
it's called it.
The colors are sort of quasi real.
Uh,
these,
these things are red giant
stars and solar type star.
It's the center of the galaxy quite
far away are really quite faint.
You can barely see it.
See in the middle of this a circle,
there's a little star there that's a
sunlike star in the middle of the galaxy.
And these circles are the
stars in which they found,
um,
uh,
in which they found Trantis.
So in this case it worked.
So it's true that one or the other,
or both of those reasons they had,
why it didn't work in the star clusters,
uh,
were in fact the reason it
didn't work in the star clusters.
Cause here's a situation where
those problems don't exist.
And now they found 16 of these things,
which is pretty close to the
amount you would have expected.
Uh,
and so now,
uh,
it is,
these are planets which have been
discovered first by the transit method.
I should say.
There are a couple of others that have
been discovered first by the transit
method,
uh,
from people at the ground just going
out and looking at random stars.
And in some of those cases they have then
done the opposite thing and gone back
and found the radial
velocity measurements after,
uh,
having discovered the Tra
the planet by transit.
You can't do radio velocity on these
guys because they're too faint.
Uh,
and uh,
you,
your,
it's just not going to work out.
Okay.
Uh,
how are we doing?
All right.
Now,
a couple of consequences of this.
If
you have both radio velocity measurement,
which tells you the mass of the planet,
okay.
And transits,
which tells you the radius of the planet,
then you know,
something very important,
you know,
the density density,
then you get the density.
Density is usually written down with
the Greek letter row for some reason,
which I don't understand,
but it's always done that way.
So we'll do it too.
Uh,
and density is defined as mass of
something divided by its volume.
Uh,
and so for a spherical object,
the volume,
uh,
if you go back to some geometry book,
you can look this up,
four thirds pi times the radius cubed,
and that's the density.
The density.
If you,
the density of water
is about what is one gram
per cubic centimeter.
Yeah,
of course.
That's a lousy set of units.
We do things and
kilograms per cubic meter,
uh,
that as it turns out,
a thousand kilograms per cubic meter.
So,
uh,
if you picture a cubic meter,
that's a pretty huge aquarium.
It actually is pretty heavy.
Uh,
and,
uh,
let's see,
is this right?
Uh,
10 to the two,
10 to the six times a gram?
Yeah,
that's right.
Um,
and,
uh,
in fact,
interestingly enough,
this is the definition of a grab.
This is where they came up with that,
uh,
that metric unit is to make it work out
so that the density of water is one is
exactly one gram per cubic centimeter.
You'd have to specify the
temperature too because,
uh,
but,
so that's,
uh,
that's a typical density of water,
which is an ice right?
Rocks have higher density,
much higher density.
That's why a handful of iron is heavier
than an equivalent sized handful of snow
a or something like that.
Um,
so if you know the density,
you can tell something
about the composition of the
planet and it turns out that
the hot Jupiters,
uh,
in the few cases we now have,
it's not just one case,
it's several cases.
Hot Jupiters have low density,
okay?
They really are ice balls.
They're not made out of rock.
And so an ideal you might've had about
where the hot Jupiters come from as well.
In these high medalists city stars,
there's just a whole bunch more rock and
earth like planet to kind of get big.
Uh,
but that isn't what happened.
These things really are made out of,
uh,
out of ice and now you have a problem
because you know how far away they are
from the star and the
temperature of these things.
Surf at the surface temperature of
these things is like a thousand degrees.
Okay?
This is not a good
place to put a snowball.
All right?
Uh,
you put a snowball in some place,
which is a thousand degrees.
Uh,
we won't specify the place,
uh,
and something bad is gonna happen to it.
Uh,
now,
uh,
the,
and so therefore,
how could these planets have formed a,
and so the idea of the current,
uh,
current thinking on this
is an idea called migration.
Okay.
And the idea behind migration
is that you make Jupiter's,
uh,
in the outer solar
system where they belong
and then through some mechanism which
people have ideas about but which aren't,
isn't at the moment really specified
these things after they are formed,
they migrate into the inner solar system.
And the reason this is a useful
thing to do is that a big thing.
Okay.
Melts slowly.
The reason for that is
that the surface area,
uh,
yes
to volume ratio is low.
Okay.
Uh,
volume goes up as the cube of the radius.
Surface area goes up as the square.
If you shine a light on something,
yeah.
The amount of energy of picks
up depends on how big it is,
not on how massive it is.
And,
and so,
uh,
changes of temperature in interacting
with your environment are,
are less the bigger you are.
This is why,
by the way,
Arctic animals tend to be big because
they're trying to survive in an,
in an environment that's
much colder than they are.
And so they generate energy by their,
by their volume,
and they lose it out their
skin by their surface area.
So you want to have a lot of volume
compared to your surface area.
Big things melt slowly.
Uh,
so you can't have ice planetesimals
in the inner solar system,
but you can't have something the
size of Jupiter and it'll melt.
But it'll take longer than the,
uh,
then the age of the solar system or
even the age of the universe to do so.
So this is the idea.
And of course,
the key point here is this migration.
Uh,
and there are ideas about
why this should happen.
Uh,
but it isn't wholly clear.
Now,
one thing,
a consequence of this idea,
okay,
is that there are no terrestrial planets,
okay?
No terrestrial planets.
Because as this Jupiter is moving inward,
if there's an earth in the way,
it's gonna either knock it out of
its orbit completely or the earth,
we'll run into Jupiter and become
incorporated into that planet.
And so if you've got a Jupiter size six
to size system in near where your earth,
like planet is orbiting that Earth,
like planets in big trouble,
uh,
for exactly the same reason the
planets are in trouble in general,
when another star comes through because
you've got something much more massive
coming by screwing up your orbit,
uh,
so that no terrestrial planets,
their orbit
are
disrupted,
uh,
by,
the migrating
Jupiter.
Now,
in fact,
I have to qualify this a little.
There was a paper that showed up in the
literature a few months back with some
clever way of preserving the terrestrial
planets as to Jupiter came by.
Uh,
I have to say,
uh,
I don't fully appreciate
the force of this argument.
Uh,
it is perhaps true because I haven't
read the paper carefully enough.
Uh,
but I sh I feel obliged to mention that
somebody at least has an idea about how
you can avoid it.
But in a,
in sort of straightforward terms,
you don't expect there to
be terrestrial planets.
Uh,
in a situation where a,
a Jupiter has migrated from
the outer solar system,
the inner solar system questions,
how are we doing?
Uh,
yes.
What causes the hot Jupiters to migrate?
This is a subject of some,
uh,
some discussion among the experts.
The idea is that when the Jupiter forms,
remember it forms out of a disc of gas.
There might still be a
substantial residual gas and
dust disk and as the Jupiter
plows through it,
uh,
the friction with that disc slows it down
and if you slow down the orbit of the
planet,
it'll gradually fall in worked.
That's one idea.
There are some,
there,
there are other ideas,
but,
uh,
it isn't clear and if it were clear,
you would have predicted it to happen.
And indeed,
there's a whole problem
with the migration theory.
So problem with migration,
okay.
Is sometimes it doesn't work because
Jupiter in our solar system is where
Jupiter is.
It didn't migrate.
It has to work.
Needs is,
so the problem with the migration
system is it needs to work,
but not always.
It also can't work too well
because if it works too well,
then the Jupiter falls right into the sun,
right?
So it has to work most of the time,
but not all the time,
but not too well.
This is a complicated balancing act.
Uh,
and whatever theory you propose,
whether it's this friction with
a dusk disc or anything else,
you've got a little problem
with this whole concept,
uh,
because you have to tune this mechanism
up so that it takes most Jupiter's moves
them into the older sister
interest inner solar system,
and then stops working at just the right
point to leave you with a whole bunch
of hot Jupiters most
but not all of the time.
All right.
That's as much as we know about it.
That's,
you know,
you've got to come back three years from
now and see if we straighten this out
because that's where we are at the moment.
All right.
More later.